hello hello everybody it is i
ethan klein the host
of one of the biggest podcasts
in the universe the h3 podcast of what
you're watching now
thank you
tired as heck
i was singing the whole way over here
i was waiting for a train to crash or
something so i was like okay
come up with that heat
pages none
wow that's art
if i could frame that i would thank you
appreciate it beautiful
yeah i was just singing um i don't want
i don't want to get out of bed today i
don't wanna i don't wanna vegetarian
no no no no
at the minute i woke up that song was in
my head
shaved
don't like seeing my face but there it
is for you all to see there it is
sometimes you just gotta
you just gotta shave it off
need a fresh
you need to try to remove it and yeah
did you exfoliate afterwards like yep i
washed i exfoliated
just doing the whole thing
you know did you use the cream
that is uh offered by one of today's
sponsors who we should read out
oh god i got it yeah yes i did use
curology on it thank you to them
expressvpn harry's and stamps.com thank
you dan off the rails already yeah we
got a good show today i mean so much is
happening in the world
um
kanye west obviously is losing his mind
we're here
what's nice about um
what's nice about having ian on the show
is that he's a kanye expert so
yeah we've got when all and when all
this kanye stuff goes down it's nice to
get his input because he once wrote a
biography
or a whole
script or for a movie about kanye's life
right ian
in another era yes i did do that
are you embarrassed that you used to be
such a big kanye stan like what's
happening now like something
i think you're in i think it's
embarrassing now to be a kanye stan is
that right
and i think you're trying to distance
yourself
where would you get that idea the last
10 times you've asked me
i never asked you that specific question
i'm just trying to understand your
aversion you're so you you i mean it
used to be such a point of pride for you
you are you're an honorary moderator on
the kanye subreddit for christ's sake
that's a huge deal
you are bullying me
every time kanye does anything i just
hear in my head ethan going
ian thoughts
they like replays i go he'll do
something insane and i hear ian thoughts
over and over that's good because you
have time to prepare your thoughts
but when i ask you on the show well said
i have no more thoughts but but don't
but it's not right you're okay you're
out of thoughts fair enough
well we'll get to kanye and then
don't worry you can share your thoughts
then i don't know what i'm doing
yeah so um kanye obviously is going wild
it's like a non-stop rollercoaster ride
there's a new meme hole of this girl who
eats butter on tick tock i want to show
she's pretty amazing
zach is on twitter
you have you have audio issues dan
is hearing something so
do people in chat hear it i'm not saying
anything in chat i'm not hearing
anything on my own okay so there you
go uh anyway we i talked about the
twinders the twinder swindler
this guy is seriously on cameo man [ __ ]
you i hate this this guy is such a piece
of [ __ ] can we get cameo to shut his
account down this guy's actually just a
piece of [ __ ] criminal you should not be
doing cameos this is the tinder swindler
again i made a video on ethan klein
during the break but this guy is like a
prolific scammer who scammed women out
of like 10 million dollars
he went to jail for five months and now
he's on cameo like acting like a
celebrity this guy's a piece can we
seriously uh can we can we tweet cameo
from the podcast
uh account and tell him to shut this
[ __ ] down this is [ __ ] [ __ ] oh
i was shocked to see this like no this
guy shouldn't this guy should be in jail
not on cameo i will say his price went
down 200 bucks in the past oh
not that rich anymore huh buddy
so this guy
first of all you should watch on netflix
if you have it
um
but this guy has been posting like he's
back on the private planes he's back in
the designer clothing let's see let's
see what his cameos are like hi
everybody i'm so excited to be here in
cameo i'm sami levive if you want any
any blessing anything birthday whatever
shout out if you want to talk on the
tinder and tinder that would be
fantastic if you want to meet in person
if you have a credit card or walmart if
you have a target gift card for me that
would be fantastic
dude i've met so many shitty shady
israelis just like this guy in my time
there i'm so tired
i wish you a great and a magnificent day
everybody take care
i wish you i wish you to deplete your
bank account
he has one review and that looks fake
yeah i'm serious who's on top of
tweeting cameo
hey simon i'm your worst enemy
[ __ ] you
i'm canceling you because you're a
criminal and a piece of [ __ ]
you're not doing cameo dude
i'm just shocked i'm i'm shocked he's
trying to be a celebrity now
hey uh my name is simon i'm a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ]
you want to do a cameo a hundred dollars
send me your paypal what am i saying hey
hey cameo
yeah this is the dude from the tinder
swindler can you please shut his account
down he has no business
being here
he's a danger to the community
did dbc is one of you says can't believe
i got a cameo from simon one of the
finest luxuries in the world that sounds
like completely yeah he wrote himself he
brought himself
a luxury
dude you're enough you're not luxury
you're like you're
gilded
he's like a can of caviar with like uh
tuna fish with like tic tacs in it
not to hate on tic tacs you know but
they're cheap
iacc how are you my friends
congratulations
we are so
so so so so excited for big connect
i appreciate it that you admire me i
admire to drew no very much take care
and i wish you a great and a magnificent
day
take care acc wake the [ __ ] up
hello uh cece uh would you like uh maybe
to talk to me or send you my email you
send me uh maybe we can meet in person i
sleep with you i steal your credit cards
i leave you in debt can you please dude
this guy's such a piece of [ __ ] he was
asking people to steal money from their
parents who were dying
to max credit cards one girl went into
debt 250 thousand dollars and he totally
screwed over and he goes yo i need more
money you need to like you need to like
refinance your house do whatever it
takes
did you watch it dan
it's unbelievable it is
he's he's evil this man is evil he would
make women fall in love with him and
then make it seem like he was in danger
and they need to get the loan out to
save his life and he then he just ghosts
them but he sleeps with them too so he
matches he finds girls he likes on
tinder
he was pre he was pretending to be like
a billionaire playboy and the the weird
scheme is that he would like move from
one tar mark to the next and use their
money to maintain the super high quality
of life where he was on the private jets
and he was having the designer close so
he was presenting that and he's like yo
i'm a billionaire son of some diamond uh
mogul
and um but i need twenty thousand
dollars well it would turn out where he
he had this narrative where he was like
i have enemies something's going
something's happening i can't use my
card for the and he would date them for
a month one of some of these girls who
would date for a year that's that's
having sex with them my mind is he stuck
with it for so long he was sleeping with
like hundreds of women at a time and
then he would rotate through them and
when he needed money he would be to one
like yo something's happening with my
enemies i just need to borrow your card
for like a week and he would he would do
to these women like
i want to get married let's move in
together he he would even send them this
was part of his game to go shop for
apartments like this was he would get
them so convinced that they were going
to be married and dating jesus so like
there's no there's almost like
it makes sense that they're like okay
well you know sure you can borrow ten
thousand whatever
yeah [ __ ] you dude get off cameo and
then he had a video of his quote-unquote
bodyguard
getting beat up with oh yeah that that's
just yeah no dude he would send the same
footage each time yeah enemies are
getting close i need more money he has
this huge bodyguard that goes with him
everyone who he would show caught a
a video of him in the in an ambulance
you should watch the documentary it's
really good yeah simon [ __ ] you dude
okay how about that
hello my name is simon ethan klein can
you please [ __ ] off i'm trying to uh not
to get a job at the uh [ __ ] gas
station you piece of [ __ ]
the
the israelis
a pep talk because emily iris
i heard from your fiance that you're
going to do your first triathlon and
you're going to write otherwise he's
trying so hard not to have an israeli
accent
he's trying to sound more exotic but
come on dude
[Music]
hey emily iris
i heard from your fiancee
you're going to do your first three
athlon and you're gonna run for the
first time well first of all i'm so
happy and i'm proud of you that you're
doing that you're doing that you don't
understand
how laughable your enemies are after you
and i'm sure you're gonna do the best
take care i wish you a great and i'm
gonna
if you could send maybe a western union
i need about 10 000 anyway good luck on
the runs ten thousand dollar tip on
cameo i know a little bit something of
running i was on run from the police for
ten years uh anyway you're gonna do
great
what an absolute
tool this guy is
wow [ __ ] you
garbage yeah
that's awesome though that he's on we're
gonna have to you guys keep tracking his
uh internet usage i'll make sure this
guy doesn't get anything
yeah science cancel culture
it is cancelled culture guess what he's
a criminal
the man is a criminal oh so so every
criminal justice i will do everything in
my power to cancel you simon you have no
business having fans or making money and
i'm not listen i'm not in charge of
cameo i'm just like hey did you guys
know that this guy's on here trying to
make money
you know
would people be okay if like r kelly was
doing cameos from jail
probably not probably not well this is
the same [ __ ] this guy is an actual
criminal
okay
he's back on instagram
oh send me the link
and there's a few i'm not sure which is
the real woman he confirmed that he's
back on there i'm guessing it's this one
i think he got banned again though
let's see let's see
so shout out to instagram for at least
banning him i mean he's a scam artist
you don't want to put this guy in touch
with anyone he should be this guy should
be getting no press
or no publicity except bad
say hello it's simon
um
i don't know if this one's real because
the real one usually he had a text like
i would be telling the truth thank you
to all my friends i love you
but this is what he's been posting he
got out of jail he only did five months
in prison
in israel and then he got out and now
he's back in like the fancy cars and the
private planes and the
gucci shirt i mean this guy's good
hello my friends it is simon lev
yeah i'm not sure if this is it but he
did confirm an instagram story that he
is back on instagram
after being banned so hi i'm fine that's
all i got
don't call that confirmation necessarily
but okay if you do find the original one
let me know
yeah let's track him
his instagram reminds me of somebody
else's instagram subflow
yeah i can [ __ ] knew it dude it's so
so the exact same thing
look it's like the same photos
yeah it's like the it's the scammers
playbook yeah so flow is the only
difference between
soflo and levi
i hate to say it but soflow's smarter
and i hate to say that
wow because his scams are generally more
obfuscated and like
it's just online scams he's not like
he's not like taking advantage of women
which makes it less nefarious like the
sleeping and lying yeah and then putting
them into debt
he's just like selling [ __ ] that he
never sends you
scammed
like uh n95 masks in a pandemic
there's a reason
there's a reason he's in south korea
folk and it ain't because he likes the
food
you know what i mean it's because he's
on the run
yeah during the height of that dammit he
was selling fake n95 masks awesome yeah
what a guy dude
i wonder if that website's still up
no
it was called a lightning bolt thunder
labs yeah thunder labs i think it i
think i checked it somewhat recently and
it was
it was all wiped
you see anything
not the store but
this
generic wix website
that he made to make himself seem
legitimate is uh oh he's oh right right
that's why we recently talked about it
because uh oh somebody pointed out here
right
wait did we ever there's a picture of
cav cav and sofia together we did we
talked about it you should message him
be like hey soflo we know it's you dude
brian kavanagh is a force of nature he
is he knows how to work with only the
best of the best best of the best
and he got banned again he posted a
story saying i'm back and now he's
banned within a day that's great well
good for instagram yeah surprising i'm
going to assume that camia just didn't
find his page yet so i'm just helping
them
expedite the uh process
hello my friends i'm kicked off uh cameo
i'm being censored i'm being cancelled
i've done nothing wrong
these women are liars
anyway if you have some target gift
cards laying around that would be
greatly appreciated
should i uh there's a contact us forum
on thunder lab should i um
i'm gonna no let's not send a request
ethan klein as the name let's not get
into okay
just curious sending stuff on my live
show okay even if it's so flow
let's do it off there
okay we'll do a link
and you can write hi soflo
uh we know where you are
you're in south korea
he's posting it
come back to come back to america
there's a there's the fbi is wanting to
talk to
prince impersonator falls off stage
okay you know i love this [ __ ]
let's take a look
[Music]
yo there was a really satisfying thud
there
damn that was a crazy professional
though what a [ __ ] paradigm man yo he
cracked on that speaker or whatever it
is
yo
i love that he stayed in character
right
[Laughter]
always a joy
[Music]
[Laughter]
they just
[Music]
let's go
all right
wow what an eventful uh yeah we figured
off the rails we're having today be a
fan of that one
and then what better than follow it up
with a
angry wheel wheelchair video the other
favorite of mine borderline
mobility scooter not quite there but how
is this not a mobility scooter well
what a body i guess it is
yeah that's that guy can't walk yeah
just doesn't have the uh
the handle on the front side but it
looks like he has two casts on his legs
i think those are just big-ass socks
though
[Applause]
it's definitely mobility
is he a titan he's biting himself he's
trying to trade
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
wow if hitler was still alive
what does that mean
i'm just saying
what that he would wipe him out he would
put him in a camp no he wouldn't i'm
saying that's what hitler would be like
if he was oh
oh okay i thought you because hitler was
he was saying like he would euthanize he
euthanized the handicap
i'm very i'm well aware by the way i'm
just saying that's what i would hope
hitler would look like if he was still
like
i think this guy is racist too
he was saying racist yeah he screamed
rouse which i think is like go go away
and he said germany let's get out of
germany
with my very very limited german german
that's what i got out of it i mean i'm
not surprised
of course that's like the you know the
go-to for anyone who's just uh
get out of my country bro
go back to where you came from
she's like ma'am i was born here
look at this we we want only germany for
the pure
for the pure blooded like me
this guy's straight out of wally
yeah the kids turkish
looks like there's a lot of turkish
immigrants there i love it man dude oh
god
i'll be honest the turkish food was one
of my favorite things about germany so
you didn't have that kebab pizza though
or was that swedish only so they didn't
have that in germany yeah they had the
durian kebab which was like uh yeah it's
kind of like a burrito
but god it was so good shaved kebab
fresh salad
yogurt
french fries yup and a pita i was like
oh [ __ ] bro and it was five euro hell
yeah boy oh [ __ ] forget it dude
just forget it
have you forgotten it
what are we talking about good
okay so i've never said
edra
that's his name right yeah you nailed it
idris elba
or is it ildra elba
now i'm afraid of saying it i know
i don't want to go ahead and say it if
you're so confident i just said i'm not
therese alba idris yeah so idris is
right why are you giving me [ __ ]
idris elba xxx i just give you [ __ ] for
saying it just now
all right idris elba i said his name ex
perfectly so here's a compilation
someone put together to you know piss me
off
got wrong i'm saying you did say idris
elvis
dad what do you guys know show the clip
or didn't have been referencing idra
elvis who said elvis
dude i never said so far okay i'm not
gonna pause it
you said idris elvis
find a clip of me saying idris elvis in
there
referencing idris elvis who is
did i really say that wait let me go
back
this is amazing
i love idris elvis
idris
what the [ __ ] did i say idris yeah maybe
i did say idris elvis this is amazing i
love no maybe i said it
albert
is amazing
elvis is amazing i love address ilber
elvis
elvis dumbledore all right
the verdict is
is uh
still out
uh
what is this one
oh yeah
we got some olympic highlights to enjoy
here
the skiing event
[Applause]
i saw this it's brutal
what country is this
[Applause]
so it's kind of hard to see what happens
but they slammed their head right
as they
[Applause]
man that looks really unfortunate like
they flipped too soon and slammed their
head yeah he was fine though he's fine
yeah he doesn't look fine
was he fine he's good he's all good no
injury
wait
don't because we can't show that if he
like died you know that right he
definitely did not die no he didn't die
give me an update on his health right
now
what happened to him
because he looks dead i mean he just
slammed his dome it's not that bad that
happens all the time in sports recovered
fine
he says he's happy with six kids
and
lives in a sunny area with
i think the important thing is he still
crossed the finish line that shows that
shows tenacity
he's uh
yeah he's kind of farm upstate it's all
good now he really is good ila sent to
super chat uh eddress ilba is my fave
she says
shout out ela shout out to ela thanks
for the 10 bucks ela 10 bucks 10. [ __ ]
you just paid three you just what you
achieved eela is paying youtube three
dollars that's what you just achieved
thank you
stay down [ __ ] baby okay i'm sorry
yo where's the real update tell me this
here we need to say we need to say on
the air he's not dead so our video
doesn't get removed this was his
instagram post and he said
i'm okay i sent the picture put it on so
ins so youtube knows and they don't
remove our videos give it a thumbs up
there he's fine
he's fine that's actually just lipstick
from all of the babes all the kisses
yeah but like i said you know listen
the fact that he was able to cross the
finish line says a lot about his
character as an athlete
he went the distance yeah i mean dude
look at him just persevere against all
odds
[Music]
[Laughter]
huge showing there what an athlete yeah
he's an olympian i mean that's the
highest honor there is in the world
stage
they have some close-up photos and this
article if you're interested no they
break it down
[Laughter]
i just want to show everyone that he's
fine no it's nothing brutal it's just
no i don't want it
oh we got the uh
party till i die
um she made a new banger yeah by the way
she was super stoked about the our
showing uh showing her a video right she
gave us a shout out and i believe so and
um
and i gotta say this one
might surpass i mean she's on the up and
up i've been singing around the office
so this is aim um bibabi
and uh she's the girl who made the
uh
to to twerk it's like it's my last day
on this
the time earth called chin up high
alright
that's right well here let's do a
refresher before we
before we
you know
rewind time chin up high like i think
wait wait wait wait wait don't watch it
don't watch too much
there's something in the beginning that
i don't think we could show so let me
just oh [ __ ] give me a time stamp okay
who cares you guys know what i'm talking
about
amy bobby [ __ ] yeah
[Music]
okay
okay
okay
building up
okay
wait is there closed captions yeah
[ __ ] yeah
i'm an awesome leader is that what
you're saying no she's a bastard
she's like i'm an awesome leader i'm an
awesome leader
i'm running for city
[Music]
that so you councilmen try me [ __ ] stop
get your dancer kill cause this [ __ ] so
yellow i can smell you from up here so
much in the pie what's the trash that
you said
what you'll be all be doing looking at
you huh
[ __ ] nobody wants
[Music]
i like i'm an awesome leader better
[Music]
i'm an awesome leader
this one's not as good in my opinion
[Music]
but it's not like necessarily funny to
watch i guess
okay
i think it's a slapper man it hits hard
yeah it's a schlapper
i like it
shout out to the bosselina
also an awesome leader
she's a girl boss
she's got girl boss energy
slay
um
how to deal when a girl breaks up with
you okay i always like to
i always like to get some red-pilled
advice is this red-pilled advice or is
it
black pill what pill are we taking what
color is the pill that's what i'm
wondering
white
white white pill
i don't know
is that a thing let's let's
sell in the clout peel white pill if a
woman dumps you okay woman dumps you
there's only one thing
that you can do stalk her
steal some panties put a camera in her
room
based
all you can do is you just need to look
at her and you say okay she instantly
second guesses herself because here's
what happens when a woman says i just
don't think i can do this anymore i'm
not really feeling it anymore what she's
hoping for what she's praying for what
she actually thinks will happen is that
you will get in a reactive state and you
will get emotional okay the second you
do that you prove her this is not white
pill bro
this is definitely some kind it's
something though there's some kind of
pill here right for many times this is a
massive test and when you pass this test
by just saying okay all right leave that
bro i don't know what kind of
relationship you're in but when your
girl's constantly trying to break up
with you
to the point where you need advice like
yeah maybe just like that's not it just
let go yeah
when you're able to do that i have
watched women break down in tears and
say i was just kidding i was just
testing i'm sorry no you haven't i
didn't mean that i shouldn't have done
that i've
effed up you're definitely like saying
that here's why when you're able to just
look a woman dead in the eyes and you
just say the words okay this shows max
notes for this yeah he's got it dumps
you there's only one thing if a woman
dumps you just say okay
she'll come crawling right back i'm
saying 100 true though in the chat
well
um he's not wrong
okay there you go
no
these i'm i'm cherry-picking some
comments most people are saying
absolutely well they'd be confused you
know if you're in a loving relationship
where you're like communicate stuff and
they're like i think we should break up
and you just say okay
like yeah that's pretty weird you know
definitely confusing they might want
closure
but like why do you want to salvage a
relationship where a girl wants to break
up with you anyway dude
i like to salvage it so i can break up
with her later
why are we trying to salvage these
relationships
just let her go bro
maybe it's a quick okay like okay
yeah that would be better it's like okay
cool yeah whatever confuse her you know
okay ethan yeah yeah
okay
okay
yeah i mean look dude okay [ __ ]
what i don't know what am i
what am i uh
some kind of dating guru i don't know
anything about it
oh man machine gun kelly cringe
we can't play this song wasn't there
another t uh machine gun kelly cringe i
found recently of
i mean it's like everything he does he
did something really cringe lately where
he was like
oh it's about the shoes yeah i'll get it
oh the shoes see we can watch that
machine gun kelly i don't know i'm sorry
if some of you guys are fans
he's very popular i don't know with who
i don't know anyone that likes him i i
[ __ ] hate his music dude
i just like i don't know him obviously
might be a good dude
uh i can't stand his [ __ ] music
yeah dan doesn't i i
no i mean like
i'm pretty sure
he's uh got a lot of
cancellable stuff in his history i don't
understand how he survived that video we
were watching
everyone yeah
he's like bro i don't give a [ __ ] that
she's underage
[ __ ] bro
hold that up i know we've watched on the
show before but it's a good way to just
intro any mgk dialogue
he's like bro
i don't give a [ __ ] i'm only like 29
i'll [ __ ] a 17 year old she's hot no he
wasn't 29.
he's like 21 or 20 yeah
i can't be sorry for being young and did
that hairline was blonde
that hairline was not it did worse it's
like so nasty though kendall jenner is
in your bedroom naked and you're 50
you're going what is this
intro
what yeah i just said inspirational
little moment if there was a 15 year old
girl in your bed and you were 50 you
know you [ __ ] i don't care my first
celebrity crush was because right now
it's kendall jenner
damn it i've said that so many
[ __ ] times i hope that
i'm snagging that don't let me move to
l.a oof
i'm fighting her counting down the days
until
she's saying i'll be outside your house
not wait until she's 18. i'll go now
i'm 23 dog like
i'm not like a creepy
you know i'm saying i'm 23 bruh i'm 23.
there's no
there is no limits right there robert
plant who is one of the greatest lead
singers
this ain't [ __ ] 1950 dude
that was 14. axel rose who was one of
the biggest so you think that's cool
that was 16. i wrote a song on his first
album positive [ __ ] that was 16.
[ __ ] are you are you saying that
that's good that they did that
yeah these are his icons i guess he's
like dude
woody allen [ __ ] his own daughter bro
don't matter allegedly
alleged by his daughter right the [ __ ]
alleged alleged by his own daughter come
on and his wife at the time
stuff this whole [ __ ] where at woody
all didn't [ __ ] yeah woody allen [ __ ]
his daughter [ __ ] sorry
but he didn't [ __ ] her he r-worded her
allegedly
by his daughter right
yeah it happened she don't want to get
sued woody allen eats we have enough
[ __ ] lawsuits what do you think woody
allen ain't doing me okay and but if he
does he'll die before it [ __ ] comes
to fruition okay if you die the suit
gets dropped
of old age for christ's sake
i'm gonna
kill yo dawg
this is the craziest [ __ ] i've heard go
back
go back and play him talking about how
robert plant was dating a 14 year old
for all y'all don't know he's sung for
led zeppelin dated a girl that was 14.
axl rose who was one of the biggest
badasses ever dated a girl that was 16
and wrote a song on his first album
about the girl that was 16.
i don't care say what you want man if
kendall jenner is in your bedroom naked
and you're 50 you're going
to yours
embarrassing
and i know he's like what he said he's
23. yes but this is irredeemably
embarrassing
[Music]
yo dawg
roma polanski
come on dog it's cool
you ever [ __ ] up a 15 year old dog
sick
yeah keep going
you know when you do like fundraisers
for school to go on just real quick
somebody in the chat pointed out that
he's actually wrong that was jimmy page
not robert plant that did that so oh
that's see that's actually slander
oops
although it's not really slander because
you have to prove malicious intent so
yeah just him yes yeah like the school
trip so like my school's big trip was
like to washington dc
and me and my friends made a vow to
steal at least one item from every gift
shop we went to so like the white house
from the gift shop the lincoln memorial
we stole from the gift shop the
washington monument we stole from the
dude are you serious right now so you
still from the white house he's so
badass are you serious like you think
you're cool right now yo i used to steal
from circle k
and i wanna [ __ ] kids bro i'm rock and
roll like dude your real name is colson
baker
dude your name is coulson baker
and you got the hairline of a
six-year-old
what a stupid son of a [ __ ]
i don't like him
but anyway also but like but his music
sucks that's the that's why that's the
biggest crime his music [ __ ] sucks
bro he got he got slammed so hard by
eminem he had to [ __ ] change genres
like he had to go go to rockefeller
he quit he quit rap it's like emo
[ __ ] like
yeah yeah
i maybe i could just play i will
actually i want to watch the rest of
this video because i don't think we ever
watched the whole video what did you
take from the white house i would steal
everything from the white house man that
place sucks
january 6th you had your chance baby
that place sucks man [ __ ] the white
house
[ __ ] it sucks dude yo you ever seen the
president what a loser
yeah i had i had a childhood that i had
two dogs
one name was dresden and one's name was
charlie charlie was a girl
but yeah
[Laughter]
you know you do the same india pet
snacks
yeah i got um i got two pets uh
fred and ned um they're located
underneath my
and they are my testicles
dude can you stop
just stop everything
what'd he say his testicles were named
go back fred and ned right or something
like that okay dude i got two pets uh
fred and ned um they're located
underneath my
and they are my testicles
dude
have you ever sex he was feeling himself
after that one he's like just stopped
just stop it all right that
all right go ahead i gotta watch this
whole thing have i ever sex dude oh my
god dude my phone is filthy it's the
worst
girls don't even like knowing yourself
like a girlfriend like grab your phone
to see what you're up to like girls know
how bad it is that they won't even like
they don't even want to see like the
extent like
guys don't even want to see the extent
like guys don't even want to like be
like oh what are you doing over here oh
let me read like it's like so nasty that
it's it's kind of like just like a
it's a bad it's like a bad book to read
i was just sexting about a golden shower
that was crazy
but it's like if you have the right
person with the right connection like
that's a crazy little experience
with the right connection okay
dude keep going this is the worst video
i've ever seen what's the worst thing
you ever did in school oh boy the worst
thing i ever did in school
was was a break into our middle school
with a couple of the kids with and bats
and we smashed a bunch of the glass
windows so
what part of your body are you most
proud of
probably my body i'm most proud of is my
left ear because it sticks out and it's
annoying and everyone notices it
and now i'm just embracing it
okay
kind of a wholesome uh
ending there
i thought he was gonna save his day yeah
i was for sure thought he was gonna wait
did he fix that ear too
does his ear no longer stick out can you
fit you you can fix it you can fix it
yeah absolutely yeah
why do you know that you look i was
initially gonna do plastic surgery you
were gonna fix your ears no no i mean
it's my specialty when i was going to
med school
oh you'd be so rich right now yeah but i
got shaky ass hands so oh
oh oh
you would have been so rich dude
damn
i know his ear is still um they still
pop in
from god love yourself
wow well anyway the reason we're talking
about mk
mgk
is because
he wrote a new song oh show me the other
one with the
the shoes clip dude
this next thing we should um we should
probably do our ads
and we got four of them today
okay but first i got to show this
because we're i just wanna i gotta
finish my thought okay gary here he is
this is what i will tell you i did work
to her and he's
i saw this on my feet and i was like
this guy is so annoying he's trying so
hard listen to this is what i will tell
you i did work to her and he
would wear comfortable shoes on stage
every day
your [ __ ] nike new balance [ __ ]
comfy shoes because it makes you feel
comfortable put on some doc martens you
put on some chucks put on some bands
like it's not about you it's about the
show you don't look cool man i hate your
feet i hate your shoes i hate everything
about your this is what
this is what i will tell you yeah maybe
you should focus more on your music and
less on your shoes jesus christ he is
the worst yeah he's so annoying what the
[ __ ]
dude he's a big interstate tattoo
like i mean i can't think of anything
more uh
white trash if i may than that so he's
getting so worked up about shoes for he
has an interstate tattoo yeah
yeah i'll find it just like the
interstate no no i just don't know which
interstate it is let me find it okay
shout out to the interstate
it's important interstate traffic is a
hallmark of commerce in this country
that's true it's huge
can we give it up for the interstate
yeah
eisenhower
where would we where would we be without
the interstate absolutely
north 71 there it is boom north 71 bb
sick where would we be without the
shores because it's like it's like it's
poser
these these aren't real punks because
they're not wearing documents what does
he drive a truck was he giving shout
outs to interstates
what's going on i don't know
your dad worked the toll or some [ __ ] he
cares more about his look than he does
with his music and it shows
thank you all right let's do that let's
thank our sponsors and then we'll get
into his new music
uh thank you to
my fave curology
i've been using this every night i love
it so much
feels amazing my skin feels amazing
here's how it works
curology is a game changing custom
skincare made for you by a dermatology
provider they create a custom
prescription cream for your specific
goals whether it's tackling acne clogged
pores skin texture dark spots or fine
lines or something else you start by
taking a short online skin quiz and
uploading photos and if it's a good fit
they're gonna ship you your formula
right to your door and even has your
name on the bottle
this is what they sent me they sent me
the
uh a cleanser which now i'm so i love
the cleanser so much i don't use
anything else it's like a perfect wash
it doesn't strip your face of oils but
it still feels clean you know what i
mean
and then they send you the dermatology
provided cream for whatever you need
and then the moisturizer which is also
really good like i do this whole routine
my skin doesn't feel greasy it doesn't
feel oily
it doesn't feel dry it's like a perfect
balance of just being comfortable
uh
you know i have greasy skin so it's nice
to find something that really works and
going to a dermatology such a pain in
the butt dude
uh just having them send it to your
house and not fussing and it's like it's
just great i really do love it i use i
use it on a daily basis
uh give it a shot man all you do is uh
yeah you take a survey
you tell them about kind of what you're
looking at for you send them a photo of
your skin
and the dermatology provider basically
makes a perfect
little potion for you
and you can get started with curology
like i did
uh for a free 30-day trial at
curology.com h3 you paid just five bucks
for shipping and handling that's c
u r o l o g y dot com slash h3 to start
your free 30-day trial you can cancel
any time and the prescription is subject
to consultation thank you thank you to
curology
[Music]
and then
one more for now is expressvpn
you've heard me talking about how
important it is to have a vpn to protect
your online privacy but choosing a vpn
you trust is equally as important
now i like to do my research on my
sponsors and i only recommend brands to
my listeners that i believe in
[Music]
i like them but i just why they make me
say that
like it just takes me by surprise when
they put words in my mouth like you
don't need to do that i like i trust i
like expressvpn i love them i use it it
just takes me by surprise
they're like my name is ethan klein and
i love expressvpn it's the only thing i
i start up first thing in the morning
and it's the last thing i turn off at
night it's my whole life
okay
now i like to do my research on my
sponsor okay
i can say with full confidence that
expressvpn is the best vpn on the market
i do agree with that
even though i didn't write it
here's why number one expressvpn doesn't
log your activity online lots of cheap
or free vpns make money by selling your
data to advertisers but expressvpn does
not do that they even have a technology
trusted server that makes their vpi
servers incapable of storing any data at
all
number two speed expressvpn uses
lightweight a new vpn protocol that they
engineered to make users faster than
ever i've tried many vpns in the past
and they sometimes are slow to connect
but expressvpn is always blazing fast
and lets me stream videos in hd quality
with zero
buffering the last thing that really
sets
expressvpn apart is how easy it is to
use you don't need any technical skills
to get it started just fire up the app
and tap on the button to connect and
that's it even your grandparents can do
it
right uh and they're let's be honest
they're the ones that need it most so
and it's not just me saying this
business insider the verge and many
other tech journalists are rating
expressvpn number one vpn in the world
so protect yourself with the vpn i use
and trust use my a link expressvpn.com
hp today and get an extra three months
free on a one year package that's
expressvpn.com
h3 visit expressvpn expressvpn.com
h3 to learn more thank you
[Music]
wonder what oh magazine has to say about
expressvpn oh oprah loves it yeah she
loves it she loves every product
oh
so here it is
oh what you got for me
the spring chicken super group oh god
that's mkg well to be fair i don't
believe that there's any evidence that
mkg has committed any sexual crimes
did you just watch that video
right but i i you know oh james charles
is in there too oh yeah just to be fair
just to be fair to him he said creepy
disgusting stuff but we don't know if he
actually woody allen literally [ __ ]
his own daughter
literally
as alleged by his daughter
and and his mom and the mom was there
not alleged it happened
thank you
so here's the song anyway to get to the
point um
how do i pull this song up
oh well we can't watch the actual
[ __ ] i just want to play a little
snippet of it yeah well the music it's
in there it's in the dark
[Music]
she only dates guys with the big um
[Music]
okay so i fell in love with the emo girl
oh wait no no no the worst part is that
he's cameoing with megan fox
she's in it hang on
wait find the course where she starts
singing and then give me give me that
time stamp
he says i am a god no no no yeah okay
let me throw this on the screen so you
guys can read along you know well you
want some backing music yeah here we go
oh this is good yeah it's actually
better than his probably i am a god
no no no no no no yeah
she got makeup by the mirror in her
bedroom thigh hard fish nets and some
black glutes nose pierced with the
cigarette perfume half dead but she
still looks cute yeah
she's a monster in disguise
and she knows all the words to trap the
songs
nope
and she knows all the words to the trap
song
take the pic
she only dates guys with big hmm
okay whatever i can't do this
she's in love with the email chorus you
drop that right at the chorus
i can't do this
she puts eyeliner on her dark skin
she tells me lies but she's knows all my
secrets this isn't that bad i mean it's
corny but this is willow's verse
okay
it's really the music
how old is willow
you can kill the music did you find the
the timestamp baby
well megan oh it's not megan it's willow
yeah i was wondering wait you're right
again wait willows on it
yeah so it's a willow smith uh mgk
collab if you will
collab since him and corpse
oh he did collab with corpse didn't they
yeah i did
[Music]
oh
god wait
all right enough
let's watch a girly butter on tick tock
okay this is a girl showed up on my for
you page again proving
that there is no
social media app like tick
out there
this girl is just straight her name is
butter girl and she just straight hit
butter she's super skinny too
which is interesting wrinkle in this
check it out
one thing about me
i will block you i will protect my peace
at all costs
i will never report commander let's tell
her your nonsense
i saw deputy
one thing about me
let me go to her page because
she's got some real bangers uh the
the one that's like covered in the
[ __ ] fruit roll-up or whatever oh
yeah yeah yeah that i think that's there
it's in the bottom right that's the one
that showed up on my on my home page
so
she's got a bowl of butter
wrapped in a fruit roll-up
a stick of butter dipping it and god
knows what no she says it's vinegar it's
like a vinegar mix holy [ __ ] yeah
yeah
yeah i was wondering her buttercup's got
to be pretty high i don't think butter
is cheap if you eat it like that oh god
just looking at it
do you find it interesting she's skinny
well she's young
you can get away that butter is gonna
catch up with her i better catch up let
me tell you i tell you when i was young
i used to eat
i used to eat sticks of butter boy
i didn't gain a single pound some of the
chad said they had a friend growing up
who did this yeah you know
i like vaguely remember a friend that
had was obsessed with butter too
it seems like
it's like listening that some kids do
when they just like munching on
pads of butter listen i love butter but
this is to me like taking spoonfuls of
mayonnaise i mean i like mayonnaise
right not like that you know yeah
there's one that has like oh god
somebody said she doesn't swallow it
um are we no she's swallowing she's
calling her out dude what are you
talking about don't don't
watch this i'm just saying i'm just
seeing one
how she watch this what do you want
she's not swallowing
now it combo smack i gotta try there
dude that combo smack oh she didn't
swallow it ragu
wait did she not swallow it i didn't see
a swallow okay
she's chilling but
now this combo smack i gotta try that
butter
okay hold on hold on she actually didn't
swallow it i mean we've got conspiracy
music
okay here here she is easy cheese
and we going
let's just find her swallow you that is
so disgusting
that is so foul
imagine you're on a first date with her
you come home what's for dinner what do
you let me cook for you
you like butter
she swallowed that one guys
she's still chewing no she swallowed it
okay yeah she's going for round two
y'all
this is real as a guess
[Music]
conspiracy
it's real unfortunately
yeah this is real as it gets i'm sad to
tell you all i was dank dude she has
kids did you try that [ __ ] yeah dude
wait do we have butter do we have butter
no i think we do have butter grab a
stick bring that [ __ ] on dude do you
want to eat it raw or dipped in
something anything whatever you got
yo so let's try let's first try it raw
and then we'll try to tip with something
it's keto too so i'm okay hold on i mean
yeah her whole personality is just
eating better
let's see
let's see
um
so they're saying we have a tub but not
a stick unfortunately the stick is
really
it's got to be a stick i feel like yeah
can we send someone to buy a stick
and with some ragu
yeah sure surrega
let's go but let's get a uh a ragu
and
uh sticks of butter
fruit
i'm down for fruit roll up in vinegar
you want to dip it in vinegar why not
it's someone available powder
butter all right so we gonna dip that
thing in there we gonna dip
this map
twix power this is hard
butter all right so we yeah but
how old
there's some commotion in the office
here we're working on trying to
recruit someone to go pick up some
sticks of butter for zach
okay
so in the meantime
anyone else want to try the stick of
butter
and ragu
i gotta watch what i eat
you're not going to try it with me then
i'll take a nibble
dan
no oh come on
i'll take a nibble i don't think i've
ever eaten butter like that so i don't
think i have either love welcome to
america
you know i've had almost pure butter
because when we make cinnamon buns in
sweden we put like butter cinnamon and
sugar
and you cannot taste a little bit before
you put it in the cinnamon yeah that
tastes great that's not what you're
doing yeah pancakes and [ __ ] you know
yeah yeah yeah
and
you're in
i don't really want to do that butter
buddies desert
come on butter buddies everyone gets a
stick butter buddies yeah
good times you guys are a bunch of
[ __ ] if you call me a butter buddy
i'll do it there you go see damn take a
stick it's too it's too heavy but it's
too good
butter sticks or butter
maybe she's onto something
i'm not dipping it in that ragu though
dude i'll probably make it better though
yeah it seems horrific no no the ragu
would make it better
absolutely dan what he's right the ragu
would make it better
the raw butter by itself unmasked that's
that's rough yeah
all right so we'll have some sticks of
butter here soon yeah [ __ ] it dude oh
yeah baby that's exciting
i'm so tired you guys i'm barely
processing what's happening right
you need a now pick me up that's gonna
[ __ ] infuse you actually you know
what i need is a saudi pick me up saudi
yeah a little caffeine yeah you got it
thank you a.b thank you baby
okay this is fun i've been looking
forward to doing this zach joined
twitter
and zach was just actually we were
hanging out outside for a minute and
zach was was
opening up to me he was saying oh people
on twitter have been has been very mean
to him ruthless man
[ __ ] ruthless like what have they
been telling you
yeah like i i put out a tweet you know i
say what's on my mind sure first and
foremost and i put out a tweet which i
was being somewhat sarcastic but
a little bit
and i'm like we need to bring back
beepers [ __ ] i miss the 80s we need to
bring bring back what beepers you know
yeah you want beepers yeah i think it'd
be kind of cool
so
i tweeted that out and i said [ __ ] i
miss the 80s
you weren't born in the 80s no [ __ ] dude
they're just they're just yanking your
chain dude
they're just tweeters [ __ ] ruthless
dogs that's not weird that's what's very
very yeah that's ruthless so much
you know uh hitler did nothing wrong or
some [ __ ] like that god i hope i don't
see that
i hate to break it too but i get that
[ __ ] under everything yeah forgetting
for getting roasted on twitter that's
like the mildest thing i could imagine
but my advice to zach was just don't
read don't read the comments don't go
and don't go down into that fair enough
that cesspool
fair enough
that's not that bad though i'm afraid to
tell you
what only awaits you not to undercut
your pain or anything yeah not you know
your pain is valid did they have papers
in the 80s i thought that was more of a
90s thing no it was more 80s
it wasn't 70s 80s doctors men were
beepers popular
so ethan uh
in this segment oh yeah
yeah yeah go ahead so um
originally what we were going to do is
we were going to compile some
uh zack draft tweets and then put in
some other tweets and you try and guess
whose is whose
now for a certain reason
that game won't work and you will see
why i gave zach all of the information
and then these are the tweets that he
sent
so you'll see
here i'll
i'll open it
so you explain what i'm looking at
should i look at his twit tweets or just
go just pull it up because the game as i
explained to zach will be guess if this
is a zach tweet or someone else's and so
this is a real tweet i just have to
guess if it was him or someone else
these haven't come out these are his
drafts
so
these are none of these
but they are tweets that he wrote that
he just sent because you have a list of
draft tweets zach
yeah
i was pretty well i was preparing for
this segment did you see his actual
tweets ethan already on because you
follow him so we wanted to throw let me
pull them up then just to show the
people what we're working with
zach it's not that spontaneous if you
have drafts
well you would have seen them well all
right we got confused because what ian
said this was supposed to be like a game
let's see let's see who you've been
tweeting hawaiian shirts [ __ ] rule a
thousand likes dude you're popping yeah
the people love you on twitter yeah
calling it right now rams 27 bengals 10.
not that far off yeah
uh retweeting howard stern wow judas
just kidding i love howard
it's wholesome content you know
you ever heard a little respect by er er
erasure that [ __ ] slaps harder than one
dollar mark night at applebee's there
you go oh this one got a lot yeah don't
take life too you've misspelled two
big [ __ ] deal
it's actually he did that on purpose
because if you read the tweet
it makes sense
don't take life too serious what like
seriously as a person no like he spelled
it wrong on purpose because some people
to get the engagement
don't take life too seriously you will
never get out alive i think i responded
to that one didn't i thank you that's
why it popped off yeah there was one
that i responded to that i thought was
really funny wait hold on it was it the
the star wars one i did
you're like i hate to say it yeah where
was that one
uh
one of the more recent ones more recent
go up yeah i just for the rest is all
the way up oh where is it
it's under the screen right there right
onto the
starting thing oh you said you said i
think it's time we all admit phantom
menace is a good movie not the best but
a good one by the way 2 500 likes dude
you're popular on twitter you're juicing
me up so i appreciate that i said now
it's not the time zach because you said
i thought that was funny because you
said i think it's time i said now it's
not the time zack
it was late it was seven in the morning
yeah and i hadn't slept yet
i was like now is that the time
in the morning
but your twitter's popping dude i don't
know what you're complaining about they
love you here thank you yes i got to 20k
in like three days yeah that's insane
dude they're not ruthless they love you
upset by those comments yeah
uh
i don't i don't know if you're gonna
last on twitter i'm gonna tell you the
truth you said yacht rock is my cup of
tea
what the [ __ ] is yacht rock you know
it's like christopher cross uh easy
listening ambrosia
[ __ ] jimmy buffett
um what else we got wait like totally
[ __ ] though is it not yeah but i don't
like he's like the quintessential no no
no what
christopher cross
okay these ones i had nothing to do with
but this one has 3 000 likes caffeine
nicotine creates the perfect morning
is that a reference to taking a dump
sure or you know my tweets are left open
for interpretation that's what i want to
see like any good work of art exactly
all right well you guys get the idea uh
so the first tweet here is i'm so tired
of people comparing my last name to
those [ __ ] bears
zach's name is uh bernstein bernstein
not berenstein
is this just a game for ethan
we all participating well it was meant
to be a game
to guess if this is exact tweet or not
right right
and
you know here's here's why it became a
bit of an issue and you'll see more as
we go so should i guess
well sure yeah who would write that
um
well his name is obviously bernstein so
i'll give it to zach
yeah yeah that's actually right yeah
that's a good tweet
you should take that out of the drafts
okay
my name is spelled z-a-c-h
i don't [ __ ] with that k-shit
that's definitely zach
that is correct yes
yeah zach's style tip all you need are
jeans
vans and a leather jacket to rock the
day
this has been exact moment that's
definitely zach that that was zack yeah
one of the biggest goals of my life is
to have a bike biography written about
me title idea let the good times roll
the zack
lewis story that one's well considering
it hasn't been
the problem with the game
i explained this will be a guessing game
to throw ethan off and this is what he
said
i i hear
i heard ian cracking up his own what's
so funny he's like zach put his name in
like everyone oh this one has his middle
name in it even i mean it couldn't be
any more specific because i thought well
maybe it's another zack
i i didn't understand the assignment
so is there another zach lewis uh i'm
going to say this one with zach
yes you nailed it
the white shirts [ __ ] rule he brought
this out the drafts he couldn't wait on
this one this one was
this one's this one's legit it was a
heater yeah that one that one's zach
yep yep
people ask
why i paint my nails
i get a lot of [ __ ] but i don't give a
[ __ ] my reasoning [ __ ] it that sack
yeah that was exact moment yeah
quality tweet
there is a typo in there it get a lot of
[ __ ]
or maybe it's missing if this go
knowledge you for unlawful carnal
knowledge
[ __ ] equal [ __ ] yeah the [ __ ] is the
acronym for that
oh what is for unlawful carnal knowledge
it's [ __ ]
but what does that mean you have to ask
what is for unlawful you have to ask
[Laughter]
what is that
means [ __ ] it's the ninth studio album
by van halen and okay i put i put that
below there yeah great van halen record
by the way okay okay do people use cash
anymore
by the way this one's zach by the way i
didn't guess yes yes you got it
do people use cash anymore i mean i
think that's zach
that was exactly yeah
well who was supposed to put in the
non-zach tweets it was meant to be
we were gonna put in like some old like
jaden smith tweets from when he was like
14 and yeah and then i start reading
these and i just i'm like
no one no one competes with zach there's
no one
to throw off the trail here no one
riding bangers on his level yeah
air conditioning overheat
any [ __ ] day
what if it's cold
i'll leave that ac on any it's every day
bro
what if it's 30 degrees outside dude i
don't give a [ __ ] i'll sleep with a fan
on and [ __ ] spread me out like jesus
on the cross naked gotta be cold
[ __ ] rock
okay rock and roll baby you ever dealing
with some pain
pain turns into great lyrics zach
i miss pay phone simpler times zack
a good tweet
thank you yeah zach was big on pay
phones yeah payphone's relationship dude
there's no [ __ ] way you ever used a
payphone you're way too young i used it
one time like i i the payphones were
like basically dead i used them a few
times and i'm significantly older than
you yeah i used them maybe a dozen times
in my life oh yeah and they were already
like cool they were already relics then
exactly he said he used it once it was a
lasting experience do you remember when
they raised it from a uh dime to a
quarter i do yeah that was me that was a
lot of tough times that was you you
raised the price me irl when they raised
the [ __ ] yeah talk about inflation
that's like 2.5
you with pay phones and beepers dude we
need to bring them back
you bring those if we roll back the clog
you won't even exist back when that [ __ ]
was popping that's true man wearing
sunglasses inside no i'm not stoned i
think i look cool though zach nice emoji
used to
there's a you know i gotta hand it to
you this is a this is a huge body of
work thank you he pumped these out i
gotta say like you have a gift thank you
this is insane
where is
sometimes there can be more poop
on the wipe than in the ball
there are problems
these are a problem these are these
problems yeah i mean that's a good tweet
reddit can be some toxic [ __ ] [ __ ]
interesting
i agree with that one
i've got the best sweets in the game
come at me bro
haha just farted
good
how many of these are there
jesus christ man
he bumps him up
everyone needs a good cry let it all out
you ever just roll out of bed before
your morning piss before your coffee and
just say [ __ ]
damn dude what what is the definition of
tweet
no matter how many dreams you got follow
them
80s love songs and whiskeys good time
are bad
[Laughter]
oh that's my favorite
i gotta have the twitter input
[Laughter]
the rocky horror picture shows the
timeless film and album we must protect
it
so that's it oh well well there was
there there was no game there no game
happened well yeah so ian was trying to
get across that uh
the game
kind of became irrelevant once we uh
saw the list of tweets here it's a joker
game there wasn't that many with his
name in it there were maybe three or
four
yeah who's gonna who who
who's writing something on that level we
could have just put a bunch of drill
tweets in there yeah it could be hard to
find uh it's a little tough to rival ha
ha just far dude
they'll find real tweets yeah i agree i
can't believe you i'm i'm impressed zack
you busted those out man thank you [ __ ]
why don't you drop a tweet live so that
the people can you want me to post one
of my drivers yeah drop one live i'm
actually i'm gonna take a poll
real quick
uh 80s
it was love songs or love or romantic
movies love songs love songs love songs
good fat good time or not should i
yeah go for it man let the people hear
you
let's see let the people hear you
let the people speak as i mean it's got
to be good times right absolutely how
could that be a bad time yeah good times
70 percent
the yeah the goods i didn't read the
needle drop one guys because i know
exactly what it said it said something
about that one album
he keeps trying to get me to get
neil dropped to debate him i messaged
him one time i was like hey what are
your thoughts on coming on and debating
zach and he goes to me
because apparently he didn't like the
premise that much
well he had a shitty [ __ ] take so
i mean it was years ago i don't give a
[ __ ] it's not even relevant anymore
all right all right the goods have it
80s love songs and whiskey spelled wrong
did i spell it wrong no i spelled it
wrong okay
well i just tweeted it so yeah i'm on
twitter i appreciate you uh sick
talking about it maybe are you are you
how are you feeling about zach getting
all this twitter attention
i'm the one that was pushing him like
heavy when he first started yeah he
really helped me zack really helped me
on instagram when i first started out he
used to push me like every day so oh
that's nice love you buddy love you
we're trying to actually get him to be
loved so
uh what h3 out of context yeah i'm just
kidding they're i don't know they keep
making jokes back i'm sorry to you yeah
lovers helped me a lot but i don't think
i can like take over that reply guy gang
game yeah
um you know sam is on twitter now too
you know that
sam's on tick tock dude sam stick talks
fire i didn't know she was on twitter
her tweets are [ __ ] gotta say
yeah the other day that [ __ ] cracked
me up
when meg the stallion said gobble me
swallow me she was speaking from the
perspective of pinocchio to the whale
most people don't know that
[Laughter]
she's so good she had another one about
wiping that's pretty good too
i that is actually new information to me
it's deep
[Laughter]
yes sam's social media rules
stan sam
sam
so we got basically there we go
is this the one you're talking about
born to [ __ ] forced away i love that
now that's deep that's right you don't
you don't have to what
wiping is definitely an optional
activity just for the record well but
you have to wipe
for hygiene and so you're not walking
around like just saying you have to [ __ ]
you don't have to wipe
you can walk around with a shitty
[ __ ] my dogs do it every day why why
would a human being want to do that
i'm just saying it's optional bro
okay
you know
like you're not gonna die if you don't
wipe your ass well you might you might
use some comments like
i don't know you could develop some sort
of rash like right
i think i don't know wiping is uh is
totally optional
i don't know why it's totally optional
bro do you think that like down like
back in the day when we were hunter
gatherers that we wiped our asses hell
no we just squatted
lose leaves you just dropped trowel and
squat you definitely well maybe they did
wipe yeah i feel like they would yeah
it's optional though
you tell me there's people cruising
around i smell people man they ain't
wiping their ass
i've never caught a whiff of some of
these people out there man i i have a
friend that's a pretty bad wiper so
explain all
should you got to teach them bro kind of
no like like like all right we need a
new poll i'm not saying
don't what do you understand you should
watch something that you're saying i get
what you're saying wiping is optional
i'm just wondering if you let it if you
just let it go for like a month or two
and you develop some sort of skin rash
and then that got infected from all the
fecal matter in the area and that could
be the matter fico
fica
matter
matter do a pull wiping is optional
that's not a question especially is
wiping optional yes or no it's totally
optional swiping optional why don't you
why don't you google it can you survive
without wiping your butt now that's a
google shoe
you you factor you cannot die
one week now that's a
the wiping is 100 percent optional my
friend okay are you getting no
properly can raise your risk for your
any truck
tract infection and spread bacteria that
can make others sick
proper wiping can also cause you know
discomfort and itching
itching wow that sounds really serious
[ __ ] comes out your ass you don't
have a choice wiping you can live
without wiping it's completely optional
you guys said no and you're wrong 73
percent no wiping is 100 optional and i
will die
i poop might say
leaving feces on your ass uh is an
invitation for bacteria to eat and
inhabit the area increasing yeah you get
your ass eaten all day that sounds good
to me
[Music]
sorry guys you're wrong on this one i
all i'm saying is why would someone want
to do that that's not that's good
there's nothing to do nobody's debating
that yeah of course you should okay sam
sweet is tearing this family apart yeah
when she gets back we got to ask for her
input on this since she well we know her
stance her tweet said she's forced to
well right yeah yeah i know you're gonna
want to walk around with the shitty
[ __ ] yeah
ian are you forcing her to wipe are you
being controlling
nah let's give lucy goosey if she wanted
to be
that's sweet
because you know there's guys and this
is something always confused me
there's dudes out there you there's like
bits about people talk about it who have
skid marks
how the [ __ ] you have skid marks in your
underwear how disgusting are you
you don't wipe i guess yeah
but at least how often are you sharding
depending on your diet
i don't sharp i don't have any [ __ ]
stains on any of my underwear well maybe
after your lightsaber incident did you
did you wipe how did you clean up after
that
well with the force guide notice this
i can't do something
is wiping optional yes
yeah that's true the quartering was uh
we traced it back to him he was one of
the yeses you know you get that crotch
rot yeah i guess that's true
all right
moving on we've got um
what time is it i want to make sure we
don't
miss our second set of ads here
we probably have to do it i mean it's 2
30 we started at one yeah we're an hour
20 in so all right let's thank our
sponsors what do you guys want to talk
about next we have uh jordan peterson
viciously attacks me kanye we haven't
talked about any of our main [ __ ]
we'll just have to blast through it
after the uh
after the quick thank you to our
sponsors starting with harry
harry my friends it's valentine's day
fairies
harry
yeah harry's did i just say harry he
said harry oh it's harry you're right
harry's valentine's day is about
following your heart and sometimes that
means making a change if your old razor
isn't giving you the shave you deserve
this year it's time to break things off
and switch to hair ease
2022 is the year to break up the new
routine treat yourself or any of the
shavers in your life with the gift of
looking sharp this valentine's day new
customers can redeem a harry's trial set
for just three bucks yup when you go to
harry's dot com slash h3 yeah harry's
delivers a close comfortable shave at a
fair price
still just as low as two bucks per blade
and harry's blades are designed to stay
sharp longer in a recent study guys who
shave four times a week said the eighth
shave was as smooth as the first harry's
is giving their
best i said i can attest to it i use
harry's i use hair yeah i use hairs too
it's awesome
i use it like on my neck and stuff
because obviously i don't use it on my
dome boy oh so that's a real you put in
the real test that's what i'm saying
and yeah no it does they stay sharp for
a long time much longer than the ones
it's a great deal
actually for three bucks new harris
customers can get a red uh can redeem a
starter set you get five blade razor a
weighted handle foaming shave gel with
aloe and a travel cover to protect your
blades when you're on the go that's a 13
value for just three
bucks there's truly never been a better
time to try harry's go to harrys.com h3
to try harry's today
and finally you know them you love them
it's
stamps
time is money
don't waste either
with repeated trips to the post office
with stamps.com you can skip the trip
and focus on how to take your small
business to the next level stamps.com
lets you print official postage right
from your computer and save you money in
the process so you can spend less time
at the post office and more time making
your customers
happy
that's right your girlfriend uses stamps
by the way who we recently met yes
allison for her uh her online store
which you can find at uh
skirts.com that's skirtswith3zs.com yeah
give it a play
definitely and yeah no she's been using
it for years and it rocks she's got her
little printer next to her uh station in
the office and just prints this postage
right there
they pick it up if it's a bigger one she
drops it off at the post office but it
seems like a no-brainer if you're
printing stuff from home seriously
saves you time money and stress for more
than 20 years stamps.com has been
indispensable for over 1 million
businesses stamps.com gives you access
to all the post office and ups shipping
services you need
right from your computer and gets
discount you can't find anywhere else
like 40 off usps rates and 76 percent
off ups
that's practically free at that discount
whether you're an office setting
invoices a side hustle etsy shop or a
full-blown warehouse shipping out
order stamps.com will make your life
easier all you need is a computer
standard printer and you don't need any
supplies or equipment
you're up and running in minutes
printing official postage for any letter
any package anywhere you want to send it
so stop paying over paying for stop
overpaying for shipping with stamps.com
sign up with the promo code h3 for
special offer that includes a four week
trial free postage and a digital scale
no long term commitment or contracts
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the page and
under the code h3 thank you to
stamps.com
we love those stamps don't we folks
i love this [ __ ] song all right so
let's let's watch yeah i love that i get
so hyped for that seriously okay guys so
lord of the rings first of all i've been
looking forward to this show for a long
time i like i think everyone was a huge
fan of the trilogy
um what trilogy yeah banger movies
lord of the rings trilogy the hobbit
trilogy was just a [ __ ] abomination
man that [ __ ] was do you think it's
gonna you know you know how people like
zach are now like well the the star wars
prequels are actually you can't rewrite
history
give it another 10 years and people are
going to be like oh actually
no i think that's right if you go back
and watch the uh
like there are redeeming qualities in
those movies
i think i think part of the backlash was
that people just they wanted it to be
better so bad it was the first star wars
movie since the originals right i mean
now we're so used to star wars just
being milked to death yeah and so
it's they're not that bad
in honesty they're really not and the
memes are just amazing it's like it's
it's like an own like its own subculture
oh yeah for sure the mannequin memes the
kid natalie portman and also darth maul
is one of the bad most badass villains
ever [ __ ] yeah he is so sick that
said
the attack of the clones the second
prequel movie movies i think is one of
the worst films ever made that that
movie does ironically i will agree with
that which one was that was that the one
yoda fought the old guy yeah yeah oh but
that fight was dubbed no i like that was
cool
in theaters
i liked you seeing yoda throw down i
remember people standing up when i was a
kid when that first happened that was
crazy i liked watching yoda throw down
did you like so that movie is also the
one with the like
excruciatingly long like romantic scenes
between uh when they're like the wheat
field or something yeah dude the guy
doesn't like sand what could you say
it's so [ __ ] bad i thought the guy i
think i think the first one and the
third one have redeeming qualities to
them i think that middle one that second
one is is one of the worst movies okay
the second one if
anything positive from the movie you do
get a backstory about boba fett
great what i've always wanted
i will say i think the best part is the
uh
the tv show the clone wars tv show i
think they corrected a lot of mistakes
at the moment that's the animation yeah
that one that was really good
surprisingly well anyway um
the hobbit however is irredeemable i
don't think there's anything good that
will ever be said about those films but
so anyway
amazon bought the rights to lord of the
rings
for and they've spent a billion dollars
it's the highest budget show of all time
was it really did they really spend that
much a billion dollars no yeah yeah
they spent a billion dollars on this
and it looks [ __ ] do you you're fact
checking that ib
it looks horrible
yeah spend 465 million on the first
season and one billion overall
is that a billion dollars does that
include the licensing because that was
probably super expensive
it sounds like
like i don't think you'll see a billion
on screen
yeah see ian said it's licensing too so
that's that's i'm sure
partly paid for that right token sun
uh yeah state so
yeah that's awesome
[Music]
well regardless they spent a billion
dollars yeah yeah i mean there's
basically unlimited budget now i'm still
gonna watch it because i love it but
like there's just something off about it
let's watch haven't you ever wondered
yeah this is like the solo res
oh yeah oh that's really bad that's fine
that's my bad
haven't you ever
wondered what else is out there
there's wonders in this world
beyond our wandering
i can feel it
that looks horrible doesn't it yeah it
looks pretty cheap
it looks like
it
is
not scary to me yeah that's not a good
thing that is not a billion dollar
scene right there
also they put this in the trailer
bro that looks dog [ __ ]
looks like a final fantasy cutscene
[Music]
[Music]
come on bezos
you can redeem yourself with this one
series
just give us a good
give us a good lord of the rings
[Music]
i do not have high hopes i thought
honestly i feel like that that ice wall
that's the only shot that like really
stood out to me as being
pretty bad looking the rest looks okay
well i when i saw this like an hd right
in front of me it's kind of dark here i
was noticing all the detail and
everything looked pretty bad yeah
well anyway the point is not if it's
going to be good or not
the point is that
a bunch of freaks on twitter are losing
their mind because there's like black
people in it
no
it's because they're breaking the lore
this is what they say because but yeah
okay so let me let me read yeah so uh
since the details of the show have
started to emerge a portion of fans have
started to cry over the casting
information revealing certain dwarves
hobbits and elves will be black
[ __ ] um
here's the threat of some of the uh
random comments d it's so funny how all
the sudden shows go woke when they cast
black people
he jumped the shark
he cast a black person
it's so obvious
and it happens every time
what are these just i was looking
forward to the show but it looks like
it's going to be ruined because of woke
hollywood leftists insist on bow brow
beating their audience with political
themes of diversity inclusion and before
you say changing fundamental character
traits such as appearance on their race
is no big deal ask a black person how
they would feel if a white actor was
cast as black panther in the marvel
universe
uh then you will see
why these politically motivated this is
such a dumb point you're not changing
[ __ ] gandalf to these are not there's
black people in middle earth
there are black people in middle earth
well i think moreover it's like it's a
terrible comparison because it's like
okay black panther
like him
being black is like a defining
characteristic of that character whereas
you know
some random elf character in this
lord of the rings which that's the other
thing this is all just being drawn from
the silmarillion or whatever which is
like the the backstory to lord of the
rings like
that [ __ ] is barely a narrative it's
it's written like a [ __ ] textbook or
like or the bible or something
it's like this the broad the broadest
description of things that you could
possibly imagine there's plenty of
wiggle room you know they're gonna cast
whoever the [ __ ] they want wait what was
even was did they even show a black
person in that trailer yeah one of the
elves is black so wait let me pause it
at the right moment he's like he catches
the arrow and then shoots it yeah so
like they're not even taking a
well-established character
you know
which is like okay at least they would
have like some argument to make if they
like turned to legolas into some black
dude obviously i wouldn't give a [ __ ] i
mean but but like it's not even that
these are characters that don't even
have a history in the book and they're
saying no there's no black people in
middle earth
um it's so dark in the trailer i can't
see
what the [ __ ] where is where's the it
was back a little before that i think
yeah right there
this guy it's so dark i can't see
anything well okay so there's a black
guy there apparently i can't it's just
and he's an elf he's got pointy ears so
there you go do you see it so just
because there's a black dude in the
[ __ ] trailer they're saying am i
allowed to be displeased now or does it
make me a racist um
if that's if yes it does make you racist
cringe woke [ __ ]
i have no uh problem with diversity in
my shows i embrace it people are people
this doesn't feel like authentic
diversity
uh this feels like a major corporation
bastardizing token in the process [ __ ]
that won't watch one second of this
trash
that is so bizarre i just i don't know
how else to describe this other than
open racism right
making him a elf
why make him an elf
uh why became an elf instead of a avari
like holy [ __ ] it completely avoids
blowing up the lord this wouldn't be a
huge problem
i can't read this [ __ ] [ __ ]
where's the quartering's take on this
oh he's i believe he's been having a
meltdown for
several days now about it
diversity edition because there's one
black actor in the trailer it's crazy
yes so of course the quartering
has made five lord of the rings videos
ranting about why you can't have asians
or black dwarves
i love all of a sudden now quartering is
like a uh tolkien
he's a
smaller yeah exactly
oh these are fire criticism is that it's
lazy
if you want to have an asian dwarf
have at it but you better have the lore
to support it you don't just toss them
in there and say yeah there's asian
dwarves now it's a fantasy land they're
not asian
he hasn't even seen the show
what lord do chinese people uh do asian
people need to tell you their lore to
exist here on earth
people look different
and like look it's supposed to vaguely
be like ancient earth or whatever maybe
they do come from a different place in
middle earth like you haven't even seen
the [ __ ] show
i'm deep undercover they're the eastern
dwarves they're the eastern clans just
say you're racist and move on bro damn
now oh oh a race of people that live
underground and and don't and don't have
any melanin in their skin let's make
them black because
oh it's because this is not pushed back
accurate that's the problem okay
it's the [ __ ] dwarves they're
electric
it doesn't even make sense
wow they're they're
they're tiny dwarves that wield like 300
pound axes dude it doesn't even make
sense how are they so strong
oh my god maybe they migrated
underground from somewhere quartering if
you want to do the genealogy route yeah
or whatever or just yeah jesus dude it's
so obvious you guys are just racist
so obvious just say it
just be open about it basically you're
mad there was one black dude in the
trailer just listen to yourself
let's go to the comments
evil cannot create anything new they can
only corrupt and ruin what good forces
have invent
invented or made so they're using
tolkien to justify being racist except
guess what
that's a fake talking quote nice but
they're like spam you'll see there's
like a bunch of it
i saw that there's like this whole
controversy of people uh
spamming the um the trailer with that
statement
and somebody looked into it can i ask
why like okay so let me read this
comment it's not about race swapping
characters no it is about race swapping
characters that matters it matters
because race and gender swapping is the
visual representation of the cultural
destruction being wrought by the woke
zealots that we that wield absolute
power in the entertainment industry
oh my god this guy continued on um dude
there was one black dude in the trailer
and you're writing a an essay
about how it's destroying culture
against and then the gaslight is always
that like oh well you just don't like
black people
yes
yep that's not it there's no that's like
there bro
i don't know how else to explain it and
prove positive within minutes they have
this art
how embarrassing do you have to be to go
make an actual video complaining about
there being a black elf in a trailer
like
he actually put this online
article they literally had this article
pre-loaded because i don't know exactly
when they announced it it was probably
like um
like uh early this morning 9 10
four hours ago this article was already
published
from slash film
oh
oh shame it seems racists won't be able
to watch
the ring he's saying they had it
pre-loaded this this has been going on
for a while now dude you had your
response pre-loaded yeah what are you
saying
it doesn't take who are you to call the
kettle black bro you made five [ __ ]
videos about a trailer with one black
elf in it now what the [ __ ] who are you
to accuse anyone of having anything
pre-loaded you sh
you [ __ ] grifter scam artist openly
racist a loser who shits and pisses in
his own [ __ ] basement there's [ __ ]
all over the
floor i don't oh cam says he's actually
made 10 videos about it really
that's what cam said oh no he's saying
he's about to make 10 minutes oh yeah
of course yeah that's true and i mean
shout out hi jeremy
i'm already taking my pants off you
gotta respect the hustle yeah so here's
actually what uh here's jeremy's version
of lord of the rings where the eye of
sauron has a maga hat on
so
that that that
that's more along the lines with the
canon
stick
also
a shout out to
make middle earth great again hats which
actually a lot of the hobbits were
wearing at the time this is canon
this is actually not one of our edits i
found this online oh you did yeah that's
awesome
and here i found more d so that's so
wait is that not ironic
i was i was saying i was thinking i i
guarantee you they're gonna be people
wearing stupid ass hats like that and i
just looked that up like i don't know if
it's for sale but i see a few of them
this is an ironic
this is a real hat
you buy this no but i'm saying people
aren't making this as a joke
people are sit are making this again i
see i see what you're saying
what the
[ __ ] should we buy one probably the
people who made this are just here to
make money out of all the stupid people
should be fair it's like during the gold
rush you know who got rich the shovels
salesman right yeah yeah
yeah we talked about that on leftovers
with all the the hog merch and let's go
brand and [ __ ] yes
these this is all they've released is a
uh black dwarf
woman
this was released in the first look and
a black elf
wait i believe they're both women on the
left is a is a dwarf yes
i think she's a female dwarves are
supposed to have beards i know it's not
candy i'm on jeremy's side now it's not
canon i don't have a problem with them
being black but that dwarf better have a
[ __ ] beard by the time this show
no
but but
i know you're you're making a point
because like
the the the women dwarves
not having beards is just as can not
canon as being black right and this is
the thing uh i i found the the actual
quote so all these people that are
spamming the comment sections of the
trailer and all over the place with that
with that fake uh talking quote
the real quote uh is the shadow that
bred them can only mock it cannot make
not real new things of its own so
they're complaining about
lore breaking
and trying to quote this guy who they
think that his you know material is
sacred and cannot be touched
misquoting him and completely changing
the meaning of the quote
of course
of course
absolutely that's right
that's right
it's exhausting man
um
let's see the quartering made 20 videos
about it
here is a different video he made five
lord of the rings videos in five days
ranting about why you can't have an
asian or what since was there an asian
dwarf i don't i don't recall seeing that
but okay let's see
some of this they know from the
what dan
a lot i don't know if it was in the
trailer but
they know about a lot of this from the
casting and that's why i was saying oh
what jeremy was saying about like within
four hours of the trailer coming out
they've been upset about this since they
announced the cast like this this is not
new information that there's black
people in the show so
they're trying to co-opt token like they
co-opted star wars and we lost star wars
the whites lost star wars
let this play this is this cracked me
off so far we lost star wars
um
now disney is just gonna
globify everything for star wars they're
gonna wokify everything
and in that process you lear you lose
the essence of what dude it's a space
drama that goes pew pew pow pow
it's not about [ __ ] white supremacy
bro
does do you think jeremy knows that
george lucas explicitly said that the
rebels
in the original star wars
were representing the vietcong and the
empire is america
because that is way more that's a robot
that's way more woke than anything that
was in the new trilogy and that'd be a
problem for him yeah
we're losing star wars
quite frankly
we've lost star wars
it's gone
not the writing
here's the casting i guess according to
jeremy
what's next
what else they gonna take from us
we lost star wars quite quickly there
was a block there was like a black dude
into the new star wars
like finn
we're losing star wars
there's a black actor
don't you know there's no black people
in the star wars universe
that [ __ ] is awoke
from death to life
star wars really was star wars was
always diverse
there were always strong females but
when you obsess when you put that at the
first for forefront of what you need to
do
uh
[Music]
you're not focusing on the right things
and
the value the good the values i want are
the same ones that was back in the 1970s
when this was made any new values i
don't like them
this is what hollywood took from us
this is this is what i'm talking about
this is white people and love
no blacks in this meadow
the only blacks in this meadows
okay never mind
that's good that's good
i'm back with the ragu and butter okay
good sam let's get that all set up here
copy that oh boy i'm starting this war
with fans right away no dude
this isn't going to end well this is
going to be a lot of people what does
that mean what are you planning bro it's
just a movie i tell you what i'm gonna
kill someone he just thinks nobody's
gonna watch it
oh yeah people are gonna watch it
referring to it as a video game trailer
which game is this
i'm not saying
i mean yeah the trailer looks bad it's
good no not because there's a black
person in you [ __ ]
ape
you you you you
you neck beard cave dwelling troll you
pit you basement kissing [ __ ] eating
freak
god
if there's a man who doesn't wipe his
ass it's definitely a quarter
nerf herder
[ __ ] you
[Laughter]
quartering's the type of dude have a
piss bottle next to his bed
so he pisses in a bottle because he
doesn't want to get up and go to the
bathroom
he could use a piss bottle next to his
computers and abyss on the floor
okay
such a loser man
the project's creative team had a
response regarding that outrage over
casting it only felt natural to us that
an adaption
of tolkien's work would reflect what the
world actually looks like tolkien is for
everyone his stories about his fictional
races doing their best work when they
leave the isolation of their own
cultures and come together they're
taking it from us
oh yeah
so what okay you don't even have to
think all right so sam is we're doing
the butter now
but wait it wasn't just quartering there
was like the crowder or ben shapiro or
any of those other users oh
i think that they're above this this is
more the quarterings uh domain
of uh cultural criticism if you will no
this isn't above crowder
you know tolkien was like
for his time let me preface this by
saying for his time because everybody
was super [ __ ] racist and yeah
exactly and then everybody still is
that's why i say when it was when star
wars was made right it was cutting edge
the social commentary was right cutting
edge and and tolkien uh from what i've
read about him generally um he was
pretty woke for his time you know yeah
dude
he um
refused
to have the books published in germany
because of their treatment of the jews i
believe wasn't a world war ii vet no
world war one vet oh okay yeah
i was like no [ __ ] uh let me fact-check
myself on that but i remember hearing a
story like english why the [ __ ] would
you want to
well a lot of english people supported
nazi germany before the war started
unfortunately
anyway
guess what i hate to break it too but
black people exist
[Laughter]
in 1938 nazis demanded to know if the
hobbit author was jewish he responded
with high class burn okay so it wasn't
that he refused to be published there
but oh yeah they wanted to know if he
was jewish so they could publish the
book or not and what did he say to them
i'm trying to find him he had a good i
love that
he had a good response i remember
reading something about that
all right you guys preparing your butter
oh he he went in on them because he
pointed out that aryans are from
the middle east essentially and that
they're completely misusing because you
know he's a linguist and so i think to
to a language professor that was
particularly offensive to him the fact
that they
misappropriated the term aryan are you
about to [ __ ] do this is that well
where are you guys
i have it what are we starting with
first well you got to wrap it in
right so we're doing the fruit roll up
in vinegar first oh i already wrapped
mine okay so we have marinara here i'm
going to try the marinara first here's
show mine
so
here we have marinara and then what's
this sam just straight up vinegar
yes yes i mean that's yeah well
all right who else is joining us
i mean i would i'd agree to just take a
bite of the butter um i'm not dipping it
did you get a stick yeah me too everyone
get a stick where's the here i'll go i
think sam's gonna get can uh no you
she's got it uh get a stick for dan and
love and a b and ian
all right let's take a bite of this one
uh zach you ready do you wanna go first
i'm doing the marinara zach's going for
the marinara
oh my god that was a big bite dude i'm
not doing that
oh my gosh how's that
okay here's your arteries clogging
[ __ ] interesting man we'll tell you
that much
it's chewy
you're still munching away on that
a little bit yeah are you gonna be able
to get it down yeah yeah
yeah he took a big old bite of it
i just want to watch him if he's going
to be able to will you eat that whole
stick so i'm going to
try it
can i get a drink though
can you melt some butter for zach sam he
needs a drink
no no no
i need like a water
that overlay though
so this is in dedication to butter girl
the number one butter eater
no no i'll be your buddy but not your
butter buddy okay
take a bite of the butter a b
it's allowed dude i'm not i'm don't want
to be punched in the face repeatedly
with all this butter in my stomach i had
baja fresh once before i sparred and
that was the worst [ __ ] decision in
my life every time i got punched i
burped onions dude one bite won't kill
you it'll make you stronger
zack you're gonna be dead by morning i
hope so dude
i'll be listening to the 80s love song
of whiskey i'm gonna take a bite with
the fruit roll up all right i'm just
going i'm going raw i'm raw dogging it
baby
i'm in
mine was mostly fruit roll up i'll be
honest oh god um i'm going to try this
is this salted butter and unsalted
no that's the way that's the way i can
you want salted this is the way
all right here we go i don't get it
show
it's a lot of butter
horrible
the fruit roll-up i don't get
yo i like it
y'all
let me try the ragu i can't i can't
swallow this
oh come on dan i can't swallow it the
fruit roll up in butter it's pretty good
i'm gonna grab a bite
okay i'm gonna try the ragu now
i'm just waiting for my text from hilah
i mean quality dude
you have to be like um
you have to have some kind of pathology
to eat that oh i'm [ __ ] up i'm gonna
have some fruit rolled up i guess
like that was a mistake i didn't it was
worse than i thought it was gonna be
the fruit roll the butter one was not
good
i was expecting that one to be okay
but actually the ragu butter was worse
the ragu was worse yeah it was horrible
yeah
it didn't work
you were saying that you would want that
rag for some reason no it didn't it
didn't work at all
maybe take a bite don't sit there and
grab somebody saying dan's the biggest
baby at least i did it maybe he's over
here [ __ ] hey baby
hey baby hey baby baby
baby
take a bite i went to high school where
i was the only person who didn't drink
out of three high schools i cannot be
pressured i promise you no i'm good i'm
sliding it over to you here you go i'm
still chugging away on this [ __ ] man
zach how much you got down of that stick
about half yeah
you gonna finish it
what's all over it what did you do oh
it's the fruit roll-up oh okay
so are you enjoying that are you doing
that just for the show do every anything
for a show i'm doing it for the show so
you're not enjoying it though not really
no
you don't have to eat that bro oh i will
though
okay
seems like you're enjoying it then
because i
i i'm not i'm not asking you to do that
for me
i'm still gonna do it for you
yeah that doesn't pass the vibe check
for me
yeah
i thought it would be like
not
not great but like tolerable but i
couldn't even get it down i mean i like
you put i put like a [ __ ] load of butter
on bread and i'll just throw that down
but without the bread yeah it's just
raw it's just goo zach oh my god you're
lip-smacking
let me see that's always lip smacking
but today i'm giving it a restaurant are
you gonna take another bite
no no no no you don't have to eat it
anymore
[Music]
that's literally how he sounds when i'm
trying to write the doc
dude you're not gonna but you're if you
get you just take a little bite of
butter what's that going to affect your
yeah it's a little bit nibble
dude we're all butter buddies here you
don't give me a butter butter it's i
mean it's it's nasty i mean yeah of
course it's sticking
just you don't have to take like a big
just
the rag is pretty good too oh stop it
you just lick it
all right come on let's move on that's
not gonna get the desired effect
uh we are at an hour
54 so all right so we have the kanye
thing which we didn't talk about at all
we have a douche there we go
kanye's
done next topic
uh it's really good though a fresh and
fit i haven't talked about let's talk
about fresh and fit fish and feet
here here's where they talk about me so
by the way
dude this is such a good evolution of
jordan peterson first his daughter goes
on the fresh and fit we've talked about
them the most misogynistic
dumbass rock bottom podcast on the
internet these guys are not smart or
interesting or funny they're just red
pill douche bags so michaela peterson
goes on there that's jordan's uh
daughter and then jordan announced that
he's gonna go on there too did that drop
yet
no
yes so
uh i can't wait for that here they are
talking about me because this happened i
guess shortly after the whole jordan
peterson x ethan clyde twitter beef
such bs by the way mikhail thoughts on
hd removing your dad's interviews from
their channel ah
okay okay
up to you yeah would you challenge us to
a debate which hey stop ducking where
are you at bro where you at we can have
a discussion on this you guys should
have a discussion look ethan i i uh
he has no sense of humor
okay i'm not gonna pause it already you
can see that from tweets he's like he's
not i don't know what audience he's
catering to because i don't think
anybody likes him like i i don't know it
was low and like what dude you're on a
podcast with like that is like
universally hated by everyone
she says in this podcast too how so many
of her friends told her not to go on
this
that's pretty funny she's like [ __ ] them
dude i like what you say about women
totally lines up with our values me and
my dad's values
i read his tweets they're not even funny
bro yeah you get zero likes on your
tweets right no one likes nobody likes
my tweets i don't know who's watching
this show
[Music]
also what is that
first of all
i removed your dad's podcast for very
specific reasons none of them include me
being unfunny
or nobody liking me so
you haven't called me fat yet i'm
waiting for that
virtue like no one cares it's like oh
yeah i'm out here i removed jordan
peterson was like good for you right a
lot of people care including your dad
and you
a lot of people cared
saving the world from dangerous people
yeah ethan
yeah he could have just taken the videos
off and just
been done but he had to make an
announcement too see i'm confused you're
trying to yeah i announced it okay i
removed them and i announced it because
i knew everyone was gonna [ __ ] notice
and i wanted to explain why i did it
i was making a point okay what the [ __ ]
do you care dude
these people that don't care about you
when you appease them guess what you do
one thing wrong you're gonna turn on
your ass yeah and i think your dad
tweeted as well they're gonna bite you
back and ass yeah yeah yeah yeah
this his sidekick in the spot is one of
the dumbest people like i think
on the planet the guy the fact that this
guy has like a quote job
hosting a talk show it blows my mind
the man is just stoned dumb if i ever
feel like i say something stupid i just
watch this guy he makes me he's so dumb
that's crazy dude he's not safe no
you're not safe at all and i will say
this too i mean this might be unpopular
this is my opinion in my opinion alone
the left always eats itself they always
do you know what i'm saying they always
because it's always a battle between
them of who can virtue signal more who
can be more righteous who could be more
uh you know empathetic that's what it is
because like here's the crazy part
nobody re i i detailed very explicitly
why
nobody none of these people have
responded to it including your dad just
like last month saying conversion
therapy is a good thing
does anybody want to address the [ __ ]
points i made
the man is pro-conversion therapy
okay
does anybody want to address the points
should i just take my shirt off and you
can call me fat
i'll give you a stick you can poke my
fat and watch it
jiggle jiggle
people that they just go the lifty the
lift
that were considered
liberals right 10 years ago are now
considered conservatives yeah me yeah
weren't you uh i wasn't around but i
wasn't in the media back then
i was i was growing boats somewhere in
college but um but yeah it's but yeah
it's amazing by the way he's so insecure
i noticed he won't even look at her you
won't look at her he only looks at his
homie they they're so adverse to making
eye contact with her it's incredible
like how people watch this ten years ago
we're considered like isn't he talking
to her
this guy's mind is blank he's not even
hearing him like
he's basically just a part of the wall
setting he won't look at her
look at him you're a raging leftist now
he won't look at a conservative so if
that does not show that we've literally
like he hasn't looked at her still yeah
that's a whole other discussion i'll
pick picking coconuts from barbados yeah
i mean what's your thoughts on that as
far as like people now because people
the [ __ ] take coconuts and barbados
is that picking coconuts do you want to
expand on that there
he's like a talking fish i think he just
points at him it's like what's on your
mind yeah he's like chicken coconuts
and
barbados is that i'm trying to see if
that's a reference that we just remember
those talking fish that would just say
random [ __ ] when you walk by it that's
him
coconuts and barbados what's on your
mind mid conversation oh coconut
do you let me go back that does not show
that we've literally like
yeah he can't even finish his train of
thought
that's a whole lot of discussion i'll
pick picking coconuts and barbados yeah
i mean yeah totally bro
that's him trying to cover him because
the other dude finished his thoughts so
he's like
it's got to be coconuts to something
it's dumb it doesn't [ __ ] matter
they're trying to have a conversation
with her
about how the left eats the left he went
on some weird tangent that didn't make
sense he's refusing to make eye contact
with her the person he's talking to his
homie the talking fish on the wall he
can't finish his thought and he says
coconuts and barbados
ice cube this is not even a conversation
this is like the sims this is like a
sims conversation
what's your thoughts on that as far as
like people your thoughts on what
picking coconuts and barbados
what are your thoughts on that people
will probably consider you like
conservative alt-right whatever else
term they want to use nowadays
i was definitely i mean i was i was
arguing with
people who are like super pro feminism
in 2013 i can remember
bro
i've hated feminism as early as 2013.
i hated i hated feminism before it was
cool
i went to an art school so it was like
an art school
yeah
yeah breeding ground so there was that
um but i'm pretty i'm still like i still
figure out i'm not liberal i guess
anymore but i'm like i'm libertarian i'm
not a conservative yeah dude libertarian
is such that's such a self-report
[Music]
i'm a libertarian i don't believe in
rules
and this they restrict the voting flag
except for the 12 rules for life yeah
good point
and the 12 more rules for life yeah
right gonna write a book called 25 rules
for life
14 pages of rules for life
right i'm not yeah so i don't know it's
def they're definitely eating their own
super interesting dialogue there
from coconuts and barbados to
yeah i'm a libertarian anyway they're
definitely eating their own i'm sorry
you can't get over that
yeah for sure no they definitely do you
know uh okay they definitely eat their
own anyway yeah ethan's an idiot who
likes him anyway they definitely eat
their own anyway coconuts and barbados
picking apples from the grocery store oh
my gosh so uh what else do we got here
let me finish up here at each chat yeah
10 bucks myron valar 10 bucks thank you
so much beast mode 40 205. what would
you say is the legacy you and your dad
want to leave when it's all said and
done is chasing purpose worth the pain
in hindsight god bless actually i like
watching this because it's so bad good
question yeah
um so i've actually thought about this
moments in the dark yeah let me go to
there's the one i thought was really
good uh that you found ab where they're
talking about marvel
this is unrelated to me but it's just so
bad i love it oh and then um marvel
wrote that in as the
nazi super villain red skull did you
hear about this no oh wow
marvel put out no full on a captain
america comic book where they have the
red skull and he's reading three rules
for life ten rules for life a little
book there
and then it talks about the red skull's
followers being misogynists and women
haters it was like based on my dad for
sure you don't have ten rules for life
by the red skull
whoa and it was like
he talks about order and chaos yeah in
in marvel it was like so then that
sounds pretty accurate i mean
her description of everything
jordan writes and stands for was spot on
it didn't even seem like they were
exaggerating it happened like two months
later a month after the times thing yeah
um but we ended up making merch instead
got it
[Applause]
mike whoa
anyways coconuts and barbados
anyway uh
speaking coconuts and barbados yeah
thanks a.b amy's doing my coat uh
damn you surprised getting my coconuts
in barbados sprung into action there is
that thing just absolutely
i'll try to continue on as you won't go
in the hole
oh [ __ ]
okay i'll keep going thank you actually
i'll wait it's probably noisy
that's probably noisy yeah
[Music]
all right thank you
well they hate we create baby you don't
have to say it because you guys do that
okay okay yeah yeah that's what we do
yeah you got to do it man because yo and
here's the other thing too i don't want
to go on a rant on this but i'm just
going to keep it nice and concise
marvel the le marvel he's cut this which
is owned by disney now if i'm not
mistaken correct i think uh yeah or is
it dc is it i think it's dc oh my god
it's uh
it's coconuts it's owned by barbados
barbados
yeah no it's marvel and dc ain't got
[ __ ] marvel disney money
whatever
they're competitors
okay so thank you for factoring in okay
so he would know here's the thing
these these are popular companies that
had you know historic uh villains and
superheroes etc they continue to push
this woke narrative
and this is why these old heroes that
you used to watch back in the day you
know back in 80s 90s whatever and you
know wow this is like the
this is masculinity these superheroes
now they're they're switching them to
women the new james bond is a is a woman
they're trying to get whoa that's not
okay yeah and it's ridiculous the new
james bond is a woman it's an
african-american woman which is i don't
i didn't watch the new james bond but it
was like a subplot i think where she
became like
he i i don't know
something i don't want to give away i
didn't watch it but apparently
he [ __ ] died and then a woman got the
double 07. i don't know spoilers i never
even watched actually spoiled it in the
office like the day after it's dumb
james bonds is dumb
so formulaic and repetitive
nobody's going to watch that
and they're making men very feminine
yeah they're making them
very feminine can i can i just say
something real quick ethan about their
[ __ ] soundbites
what are they doing did they play the
nelson yeah
and then the record scratches air horns
i mean come on nelson laughs i love when
when she's talking and the dude's
looking right at her and he pushes a
loud ass sound bite and she's like did
you just did you just push that there's
a point in the podcast where she's so
surprised that he's pushing his own uh
sound bites look at the body language
timing is everything look at the body
language this is the guest
they will not look at her
that's what's honest their conversion
therapy more what what is this
yeah that's the red skull i mean
basically
[Laughter]
to like push this social narrative of
acceptance being woke being politically
correct being progressive right and what
we're doing is we're diluting the
quality of the of the content and this
is why box office is bombing with a lot
of these movies yeah you know what i'm
saying marvel has been taken marvel is
the [ __ ] god of box office
the highest grossing movie of all time
it's just nothing he says is based in
reality in any way
freaking l's for several years now at
this point i mean the captain martial
spider-man just was like now number
three of all time domestically yeah
during a pandemic yes
they can yeah they're getting crushed at
the moment which one is the one that had
uh mo you're the pop pop culture guy
here
um
it was captain that bombed right the
marvel movie that bombed scarlett
johansson had one too black widow black
widow that one bombed nope nope no that
one did fine that one was in the top 10
grossing films but why was that well
because it had a woman lead like sorry i
guess yeah
the point is it's in the comic book
there's women in the comic book
that they're taking these traditionally
masculine characters listen to this part
hold on as he's saying
uh let me just play show you a picture
of thor
one of the main characters
of the marvel
universe and just talk we're going to
talk about how
they're ruining masculinity here
you could just see how on point he is
here
for because i was so sick for so long
you and your dad want to leave when it's
all said and done is chasing perfect
when you go to the doctor for a
lifestyle what's happening
where am i
i didn't touch the timeline oh no oh no
wait i think i know what happened it's
around the 25 mark picking coconuts and
barbados right now situation they're
making the superheroes here here here i
i figured out what happened
the point is is that they're taking
these traditionally masculine characters
that were created back in the 50s and
60s etc they're trying to make them woke
they're changing the situation they're
making the superheroes that were men
women now they're trying to appease this
narrative and it's it's ridiculous and
they're losing money for it because
people
always vote with their wallets and i'm
glad that hollywood is taking a hit with
all this stuff go whoa wait you deserve
to go broke baby you're not saying
marvel is not going broke dude he's just
wrong about everything according to the
observer black widow was highest
grossing domestic movie of 2021 back in
september and the fifth highest
worldwide
oops and also it's woke for having a
woman lead look at man they're ruining
masculinity also
have they
have they gender swapped any characters
in marvel no like they're totally
they're totally true to the character
this crazy masculinity i think maybe
maybe captain marvel
a version of captain marvel was a male
at some point there's another multiverse
version but the original
right captain
girl right who ends up dating rhodes
yeah they're ruining masculinity my
goodness
wait hold on captain america shirtless
third strap alert hold on
god they're ruining masculinity it's
like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] he's like a [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
dude they're ruining masculinity with
this [ __ ]
back to the thing
okay
well the internals were just a bad movie
guys i didn't finish that i was like oh
this has so many
oh that was awful yeah that was awful i
didn't watch it there is so much virtue
signaling nowadays in movies that it's
ridiculous and it's no it's no wonder
that the box office consistently is
crashing and failing and everything else
like that because they can
he's actually wrong about everything
he's saying it's incredible you can just
say anything you want and people just
for some reason listen continuously
feminized i hate say like that but she
hasn't said anything they're talking to
each other
this started with tim asking her a
question about her dad's legacy and he's
ranting about how marvel is a box office
fl like these guys are so inept and so
this is why i originally wanted to
debate them but i thought
they're so irrelevant and just trash
apparently
a character in black widow was gender
swapped
oh no yeah
i guess that's why it was a task master
i guess that's why it was a uh box
office bomb right abby that must have
been my god yeah i guess so well i'm
sure that one did poorly compared to
others but because there was a [ __ ]
pandemic and all that it made a shitload
of money yeah and it was released on hbo
max not in theaters or well it was
simultaneously yeah
yeah
man
you know what i'm saying like if i if i
grew up on spider-man in the 80s and 90s
and i'm watching spider-man and he's
doing some weird [ __ ] it's not like it's
not the peter parker that i know like
[ __ ] this i'm gonna go watch the
original stuff that i grew up on and
that's what people are doing you know
you know you don't like the boy
spiderman nah not as much what good
what are you talking about
he is literally the same did the same
[ __ ] there's a problem right what the
[ __ ] are you saying bro he's not massive
he's just a boy not a that's what who
peter barker is exactly he's a high
school boy
how can you cast him any better
tobey maguire is more nerdy looking by
the way so what the [ __ ] are you saying
the new people also got spider-man's up
to some weird [ __ ] what like dating a
black girl is that what
he's dating a black girl right we know
that they have a big issue with that
actually yeah so maybe yeah that's a
problem
yeah
you know you don't like the boy
spiderman i'm watching spider-man but
he's doing some weird [ __ ] it's not like
it's not a little bit she's like
well there's some woke side characters
actually yeah actually he's definitely
just talking about zendaya zendaya
zendaya yeah zendaya being in the movie
what a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] what a
loser you are and by the way your
criticism is that it kills them in the
box office that's why spider-man is like
one of the highest grossing
no way home
third already third in the world yeah
the whole the whole go woke get broke
narrative or whatever it it doesn't
really work on marvel considering i
don't think seriously the premise is
ridiculous because they they're not woke
they're not overly woke no they just
cast a black person
again which is all it takes for these
people to lose their mind yeah maybe
he's mad this spiderman doesn't like
make his own natural spider jizz it has
to come out of like the machine the
cartridge
is upsetting yeah he likes the natural
it's about the original stuff that i
grew up on and that's what people are
doing you know you know you don't like
the boy spider-man
oh not as much by the way this guy said
he he doesn't like or he hates black
women so
it lines up that uh
that that would be the case he said he
wouldn't yeah he would never date a
black woman yeah
what i mean
it wasn't bad but it's not what you're
used to it's not what you must say this
the new generation that's all they see
so here's the problem right we are used
to the masculine more traditional
superheroes but the kids of this
generation it's all they know so then
they're thinking okay this is the gospel
this is what it really is yeah and then
they kind of react right now that in
real life and i will say that spider-man
is not a dude he is
he can barely articulate a single
thought it's awesome man
i want to debate just him you think
that's possible
just the sidekick just the talking just
fit
no fresh yeah no fresh just fit whoever
i don't know what yeah
is the best of the worst there are some
dislikeable side characters and
spiderman yeah they kind of put the woke
agenda in through them do you hear what
you're saying
the woke agenda through the side carrier
occurs that i dislike what's the woke
agenda one is his girlfriend is black
and his friend is asian do you hear what
you're saying you [ __ ] openly racist
loser freaks
this is a clan meeting
just straight up
i agree with that yeah that is true yeah
and and and it's also there's so many
things that go on like you know they
they typically make the guy like the
villain is like a traditionally
masculine man who's white right they do
that okay so you
you want white people in the movie or
not
the villains white
that's the problem there's so like
there's a lack of white people in the
marvel movies what is the point being
made here
he's the problem is that if you're going
to make anyone
diverse at least make it the villain
which is how i usually see them right
black panther is the only
black superhero oh a war machine war
machine so okay so there's two
versus all of the other avengers
i mean these p that's what these people
want the quartering only wants lando to
be the only black dude in the whole
galaxy right
and vader's voice that's it
and then they make the hero you know uh
someone that is more you know how do i
say this more left leaning to some
degree some virtual signaling person
that matches a certain criteria to make
them look good related and yeah more
relatable and that's the thing like no
one's going to talk about this because
if you say that why don't you say what
you're talking about
and what left like i'm sorry the marvel
movies like
black panther the hero is a [ __ ] cia
agent like his his like buddy that helps
him solve the problem you know what not
it's not america is openly antifa now
that's some left-wing she's she's in the
air force
nazis i can't imagine what's more left
winning woke propaganda than that oh my
god the chat is saying falcon is also
oh falcon right yeah okay so there's a
couple there's a handful
so what do you think should we debate
these guys they're not even worth it
wouldn't it i would love to see you and
hassan oh hassan would destroy these
games
but i actually just want to talk to his
homie i don't care about this the
coconut dude yeah just the coconut
barbados
oh
oh you're a bigot oh you're racist oh
you're massages oh you are because like
especially considering you're not even
referencing anything specific everything
you've said is wrong
you are all those things oh you're toxic
oh you're insecure small thick energy by
the way he gets so upset when people say
he has small dick energy he brings in
every art he has a tiny [ __ ] like
there's no debating at this point
he's got such a small dick dude it's
crazy
yeah one of those so you should be
progressive yeah so i'm not surprised
that marvel can someone do me a favor
somebody make a super clip of his of
coconut and barbados everything he says
in an episode i want to watch a
compilation and just let it just his
input that's it that's all i want yeah
for sure
we'll call it dc fresher fit do you know
abe have you figured it out which one's
which yet he uh he doesn't know yet i
was gonna say
let's do a cut of him coconut
we'll call it the uh rotten
and unkept
would take that chance
to be by the way super engaging
conversation with their guests
welcome uh michaela peterson to the show
who they haven't even looked at once
have you seen any either one of them
turn to address her straight on
no
record scratch moment oh i'm wrong uh
the coconut guy is uh is fresh he's
fresh the other guy's fit
okay interesting
oh in here
sure enough
there they are
yeah i can't wait for that man it's
gonna be so good epic
jordan i i i heard that uh if you go to
barbados the coconuts are
what are your thoughts on the coconuts
progressive and woke and try to use that
you know to push a virtual signaling
agenda which is ridiculous they're
totally misjudging the population too
yeah like this is what people want to
hear because that's what you see in new
york times and mainstream media but it's
not actually what people want to hear
obviously
what are you talking about
no they're not what are you talking
about box office failures dan
go woke go bro just like spiderman no
way home
how dare they cast a black mary jane
that everybody loves
the world is crazy about the sentence
even the quartering uh likes the
spider-man movies no single person is
mad about uh mary jane being black no
one
i have nearly 50 videos on the woman
[Laughter]
man right now take it baby take it yo
it's funny a lot of these podcasts i
went up and debate these guys they're
more viewers than some of these people
yeah
yeah funny
they're trying to go after joe rogan
exactly right oh heart taking it out
daddy i just i mean you guys probably
know about this but the white house went
after him oh yeah yeah oh they did and
then uh it was the press secretary i
know the medical people went out the
medical community went after him he was
yeah
the medical community
that's a good way to put it
i appreciate him saying that an accurate
way oh the entire medical yeah we have
to go right yeah i was gonna say there's
as fun as much fun as we're having these
guys are the worst man maybe
can we do a poll real fast should we
have these guys on to debate or no
i mean obviously we're going to destroy
them it's not going to be like
i'm not worried about that but i just
it's just
i just want to debate fresh what if just
fresh comes on hassan and fit and then
you and fresh
what are you what are you trying to say
that i'm only equipped to debate fresh
now you guys got one iq point you might
know more about coconuts than hassan i'm
saying hassan meanwhile because i'm
[ __ ] middle eastern oh we're both
middle eastern we're both actually i'm
actually not middle eastern
[ __ ] your mom sorry how about that
russian fit debate what just yes no
yeah just yes or no yeah i would do it
with hassan or yeah
yeah that would definitely be
leftover special or fresh whatever the
[ __ ]
i would love to just have fresh on dude
that would be so iconic
maybe we could make that a a condition
we'll debate you but only fresh yeah no
for sure
so it's a one-on-one yeah
fit sorry take the day off
let's see fresh and fit are
biting their nails right now they're
desperate for the okay so the people do
want it that's good
we're gonna have to make this happen
then
we can debate marvel movies we'll start
there
the failure of woke marvel movies
i've seen his song reacting to some of
their stuff before too so i'm sure he's
uh
all right so so can someone reach out
and let's get it let's get a special
let's get a special episode going we'll
get hassan in here yeah
and like we can even have like debate
topics or i don't know what's the best
way to
debate
see what they want to debate
you know we could start with marvel
let's debate whether whether uh marvel
movies are too woke
and if it's if they're bombing as a
result that's the i mean that's just
talk it's not even debate that's just
reality like it's just
whatever
all right you would lose the debate dan
because reality is not a factor all
right i can't wait i can't wait i can't
wait to talk to them
so i would be there uh
who'd be there sam cedar who could we
spring on them
that girl that girl that dressed them
down on the girl that destroyed them
let's just show them a feed of
themselves
trip
pictures of their mom probably their
moms
all right so someone reach out who's
going to take that that mantle up well
let's talk about it okay so we're going
to reach out we're going to make this
happen
people are saying don't give in cells a
platform dude they're not getting i mean
that was kind of my attitude they're not
getting up there they're going to
look like morons yeah you're going to
get to clap dude
yeah i mean it's true
yeah there's a that's the thing it's
like i had jordan on i didn't challenge
him at all propped him up okay that's
the problem when you bring someone and
challenge them and you're ready it's
different you can talk to someone you
disagree with or even despise
if you're challenging them in a way that
doesn't just uh put them on a pedestal
you know what i'm saying yeah no that's
a fair point
absolutely i mean that girl dominating
them was great we all enjoyed that we
would have never heard about them almost
that had happened i think
they someone says they will not accept
he's bitching and whining that they want
to debate us and that i'm dodging him
did you point out that
that happened like while you were at the
hospital having your your body oh yeah
my wife was ila was giving birth and
he's like stop hugging me bro
i guess to be i'm sure he didn't know
that but but yeah that was why he was uh
ducking and dodging you if you see this
fresher fit whichever one you are
nobody's talking about you was having a
child let's see this
coconuts something that you will never
experience
well i don't think it's hard to have a
baby it's really easy well you have to
have sex
right absolutely i don't
i don't think fresh is getting much play
either
takes it by force oh
fresh fresh careful
allegedly how much
why do you think he's fit
you're implying that he's a sexual
predator yeah well we don't know that
yeah i do
i'm just kidding i'm just kidding
[Laughter]
did you run condoms no i know that
yeah i'm just kidding obviously what the
[ __ ] do i know why don't you take a seat
right over there i mean he likes to stay
in shape
ecto vergo
what's up what's the phrase there if
therefore
vis-a-vis
and ergo
concordantly there we go
are we just doing the architect speech
oh right right the architect all right
that's a show that's a wrap
that's a wrap we will be back on friday
with ela she'll be here i wasn't sure
yeah yeah she'll be honest
sorry guys for that whole
joke there but sometimes it's just you
gotta say it
sometimes you just gotta say what it's
on your brain and heart
like coconuts and barbados
did you guys say it
i need to know the context there had to
have been something that prompted that
maybe someone knows but i don't think so
i think that's just what's in his head
like homer simpson when he's like yeah
yeah donuts
strawberry sprinkled doughnuts he's got
a little black and white cartoon going
on his brain
all right guys thanks for watching we'll
see you on friday stay good stay blessed
[Music]
that's it
[Music]
[Music]
you